Only the Bible has the answers. Let's go
to the scriptures, line upon line, and
let's see what the Bible says about the
timing of the rapture. Is it preerttrib?
Is it post-trib? Is it pre-wrath, as
some people say? We're going to find
out. We're going to go straight to the
scriptures. So, there was a movie in the
70s called A Thief in the Night. And it
comes from a scripture in the Bible.
They're saying this concept is look, you
could be here and millions of people
could disappear and you're still here.
Does the Bible teach that? This uh the
title of this movie, A Thief in the
Night, comes from the scripture 2 Peter
3:10. And it says, "But the day of the
Lord shall come as a thief in the
night." See, he's going to come
unexpectedly, take us away, and some are
going to be left, and some are going to
still uh you know, some are going to be
caught up, some are going to be left,
and uh that's it, right? But read the
rest of the scripture. It says in the
which the heavens shall pass away with a
great noise and the elements shall melt
with fervent heat. The earth also and
the works that that are therein shall be
burned up. When you actually read the
scripture about a thief in the night,
does it say that um you know someone is
here and then Jesus comes like a thief
in the night and millions of people
disappear and some people are left? No.
It actually says that that the heavens
shall pass away with a great noise, and
the elements shall melt with fervent
heat, and the earth also and the works
that are therein shall be burned up. So
why would you name a movie about a
pre-tribulation rapture? Why would you
name it a thief in the night when the
scripture literally says that this is
going to happen in the same time that
the earth melts away? Nobody's going to
be left behind in that scenario. There
is actually another scripture that talks
about the thief and the knife scenario
though and it's 1 Thessalonians 5 2 and
3 and it says for yourselves know
perfectly that the day of the Lord shall
cometh as a thief in the night. There it
is. For when they shall say peace and
safety then sudden destruction shall
come upon them as travail upon a woman
with child and they shall not escape.
So, is this describing a scenario where
millions of people disappear and some
are left behind for hell on earth? No.
It says that when this event happens,
this thief in the night event happens,
that there's going to be sudden
destruction is what it says. Sudden
destruction will come upon them. This is
going to give you the scenario of where
this title came from. The end of the
harvest. It says, "The kingdom of heaven
is likened unto a man which sowed good
seed in his field. But while men slept,
his enemy came and swed tears among the
wheat and went his way. But when the
blade was sprung up and brought forth
fruit, then appeared the tears also." So
the servants of the householder came and
said unto him, "Sir, did thou not sow
good seed in thy field? From whence then
hath hath it tears? He said unto them,
An enemy hath done this? The servant
said unto him, Wilt thou then that we go
and gather them up? But he said, Nay,
lest while ye gather the tears, ye root
up also the wheat with them. Here's an
interesting point. Let both grow
together
until the harvest. And in the time of
the harvest, I will say to the reapers,
gather ye together first the tears, and
bind them in bundles to burn them, but
gather the wheat into my barn. So, I
want to like point out some interesting
phrases here. Notice it says, "Let them
grow together. Let the wheat and the
tears, the wicked and the righteous,
grow together. How long do they grow
together? Until the harvest, and what is
the harvest? The harvest is when the
angels come and gather the the
righteous. Right? But here it says, "And
I will tell the reapers, gather first
the tears." The tears are the wicked.
So, wait a minute. We've been taught
that that the angels are or that Christ
is going to gather the righteous first,
right? But this says, "Gather the tears
first and bind them in bundles to burn
them." And then it says, "Gather my
wheat into my barn." So it's like,
"Gather the wicked to burn them, but
then protect my righteous ones."
Then they asked him to clarify because
this was a parable. It was talking about
wheat and tears and reapers and all
these things. So in Matthew 13:37-47,
he clarifies and tells them plainly and
he says, "He that seweth the good seed
is the son of man. The field, here's the
parable, the field is the world." So now
he's telling you this symbol of the
field, it's literally the world. The
good seed are the children of the
kingdom, but the tears are the children
of the wicked one. The enemy that swed
them is the devil. The harvest is the
end of the world. If he said, "Let them
both grow together until the harvest."
He's literally saying, "Let them both
grow together until the end of the
world." Like it says right here. And it
says, "And the reapers are the angels.
As therefore the tears are gathered
together and burned in the fire, so
shall it be in the end of this world.
The Son of Man shall send forth his
angels, and they shall gather out of his
kingdom all things that offend." So it's
the tears, it's those that offend that
he's gathering first. And them which do
iniquity, the sinners, and shall cast
them into a furnace of fire. There shall
be wailing and nashing of teeth, then
shall the righteous shine forth as the
sun in the kingdom of their father. Who
hath ears to hear? Let him hear. Oh
Lord, I pray that there's people here
that have ears to hear. See, it says,
"Let them both grow together until the
harvest." And then he says, "The harvest
is the end of the world." So Jesus
clarifies and makes it plain. Then it
says, "Gather ye together first the
tears and bind them in bundles to burn
them." Then it says, "So shall it be in
the end of this world. The son of man
shall send forth his angels, and they
shall gather out of his kingdom all
things that offend and them which do
iniquity, and shall cast them into a
furnace of fire. There shall be wailing
and nashing of teeth. And then here it
says, "Gather the wheat into my barn."
And he says, "Then shall the righteous
shine forth as the sun in the kingdom of
their father." So Left Behind, we saw
this movie back when uh it was Kurt
Cameron. Then it came out again with
Nicholas Cage. Did Hollywood actually
get it right? Did they actually get it
right when they told us that um some
people are going to be left behind? the
wicked are going to be left behind and
the righteous are going to be caught up
to meet the Lord in the air. But the the
name left behind, it actually comes from
Matthew 24:37-4.
And it says, "As the days of Noah were,
so shall also the coming of the Son of
Man be. For as in the days that were
before the flood, they were eating and
drinking, marrying and giving in
marriage, until the day that Noah
entered into the ark. And they knew not
until the flood came and took them all
away. So shall also the coming of the
son of man be. Two shall be in the
field. The one shall be taken and the
other left. So one is left behind. The
wicked are left behind. Right? Let's
study it out. Let's really look and see.
Does it really say that the wicked are
left behind? Notice that it says took
them all away. It it's it compares
Christ's second coming to the days of
Noah. And it says, "So shall also the
coming of the son of man be." So let's
see what were the days of Noah like. It
says that they were eating and drinking
and all these things. And then it says,
"And knew not until the flood came and
what in yellow and took them all away."
So what took the people? Was it the
righteous or the wicked who were taken
during Noah's day? It says the flood.
That's destruction, the punishment. The
flood was the thing that took the wicked
away. And then it says, "So shall also
the coming of the son of man be, saying,
just like then is going to be the coming
of the son of man." And how does it
describe it? Then two will be in a
field, and one shall be taken. So if
it's just like the days of Noah, is
taken a good thing or a bad thing? No,
it's a bad thing. the wicked will be
taken by destruction. And yet Satan has
twisted this theology and said, "You
don't want to be left behind.
You want to be taken, right?" But that
is the that's how Satan does it. He
counterfeits everything. He twists and
perverts everything so that everything
is Babylon confusion and nobody knows
what's right and wrong and what's up and
down and good is bad and all these
things. And he's literally got people
saying, "I sure don't want to be left
behind." And yet that's exactly what we
want to be. Luke 17:34-37
says, "I tell you in the night that
there shall be two men in one bed, and
one shall be taken and the other shall
be left. Two women shall be grinding
together, the one shall be taken, and
the other left. Two men shall be in the
field. The one shall be taken and the
other left." And they answered and said
unto to him, "Where, Lord?" So they're
saying, "Where are these people being
taken?" And he explains, he says, "And
he said unto them, wheresoever the body
is thither will the eagles be gathered
together." They're saying, "Where are
these people being taken?" And Jesus is
saying, "Their carcasses where the body
is, the eagles are going to gather
together and eat their carcass." He's
saying they're not going to be taken
anywhere. They're going to be left to be
vulture food. And to prove this point,
there's another parallel verse and it
says in Matthew 24:25-31
and it says, "Behold, I have told you
before. Wherefore, if they shall say
unto you, behold, he's in the desert, go
not forth. Behold, he's in the secret
chambers, believe it not. For as the
lightning cometh out of the east, and
shineth even into the west, so shall
also the coming of the Son of Man be."
And here it is. For wheresoever the
carcass is, there will the eagles be
gathered together. When does this
happen?
Immediately after the tribulation of
those days, the sun shall be darkened
and the moon shall not give her light,
and the stars shall fall from the
heaven, and the powers of heaven shall
be shaken. And then, wait a minute,
immediately after the tribulation, and
then shall appear the sign of the son of
man in heaven. And then shall all the
tribes of the earth mourn, and they
shall see the Son of Man coming in the
clouds of heaven with power and great
glory. And he shall send his angels with
a great sound of a trumpet, and they
shall gather together his elect from the
four winds of the from the four winds
from one end of heaven to the other. Now
listen, people will say, "No, no, no.
You're this is the second coming. This
isn't the rapture. This is the second
coming." But wait a minute, it just now
described the rapture event. It's
talking about the sound of a trumpet.
It's talking about gathering the elect,
right? So, this is definitely the same
event. The second coming is the rapture.
There is no rapture before the second
coming. And we're proving that right
here. Immediately after the tribulation,
the righteous will be gathered at the
sound of the trumpet. In the blink of an
eye is another movie title. where they
get this movie title. This is about the
rapture from Pure Flicks. And the movie
title comes from 1 Corinthians 15:51-53.
And it says, "Behold, I show you a
mystery. We shall not all sleep." Which
is interesting concept because the dead
are asleep. They're dead. They're not
awake. They're not conscious. But we
shall not all sleep, but we shall be
changed. When does that change happen?
In a moment, in the twinkling of an eye,
at the last trump, that change, that
resurrection, into your new body doesn't
happen until the last trumpet. For the
trumpet shall sound, and the dead,
they're dead, they're not alive, shall
be raised out of their graves,
incorruptible, and we shall be changed.
For this corruptible must put on
incorruption, and this mortal must put
on immortality. This is another false
doctrine that we're taught that everyone
has immortality, that when you die,
you're going to spend eternity somewhere
in heaven or hell, immediately at death,
you're going to be conscious for
eternity somewhere. But that's not what
the Bible says. It says that you're
asleep, that you're dead, and that one
day at the last trumpet when Christ
returns, you're going to be raised out
of your grave, and then you're going to
put on immortality and incorruption. But
I wanted to point out that the timing is
at the last trumpet. We know that there
are seven trumpets in the book of
Revelation. So the last trumpet is after
the plagues are poured upon the earth.
This is a parallel to 1 Thessalonians
4:16-1 17. It says, "For the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout, with the voice of the archangel,
and with the trump of God, and the dead
in Christ shall rise first. Then we
which are alive and remain shall be
caught up together with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air. And
so shall we ever be with the Lord. So
there's only one resurrection of the
righteous. There's only one catching up
of the righteous. It happens at the same
exact time. The rapture happens at the
same time as the resurrection of the
righteous and it happens at the second
coming and no time before that. You
notice these are the same event because
people will say, "No, uh, one of these
is describing the rapture and one is
describing the second coming." But no,
they're the same event. They're both
describing the last trump, the trump of
God. The dead in Christ shall be rise
shall rise from the dead and be caught
up to meet the Lord in the air. Now,
like I was saying, Revelation describes
seven trumpets. These trumpets happen as
plagues are being poured upon the earth.
So if a trumpet sounds and a plague's
poured and another trumpet sounds and a
plague is poured, then what does that
mean? It means that the rapture happens
after the plagues, we Christians will be
on the earth as the plagues are being
poured upon the earth. Listen to me
clearly because people will say, "No,
we're the bride of Christ and God isn't
a wifebeater and all these things." They
say all these crazy things, but what
does the Bible say? It says that we will
not rise from the dead. We will not be
caught up until the last trumpet.
There's seven trumpets. Plagues are
being poured upon the earth. We're here.
But then at that last trumpet, we will
be caught up to meet the Lord in the
air. Now, you say, "Why would God punish
the righteous?" He's not. Where were the
Israelites when the plagues poured upon
Egypt? They were right there in Egypt.
And that was 10 plagues. This is only
seven. If God protected his people
through 10 plagues in Egypt, he can do
the same for us in the last days. We
will be here as a witness to all
humanity that God protects his people
and that we will be caught up to meet
the Lord in the air. I used to only hear
preerttrib, post-trib, and midtrib. But
now there's a concept that says
posttrib, but pre-wrath. So let's see if
that's true. It says, "But man dieth and
wasteth away. Yay, man gives up the
breath of gives up the breath, and where
is he? As the waters fail from the sea,
and the flood decayth and dryth up, so
man lith down and riseth not. So, we're
not going to heaven. We're not rising.
We're not alive. We're dead. It says,
"And man riseth not till when? Till the
heavens be no more? They shall not
awake," meaning they're asleep, "nor be
raised out of their sleep. Oh, that thou
wouldest hide me in the grave." So where
are you when you're dead? You're in the
grave. That thou wouldest keep me secret
until when? Until thy wrath be passed.
So this resurrection of the dead in
Christ doesn't happen until after the
wrath is passed. That thou wouldest
appoint me a set time and remember me.
If a man dies, shall he live again? All
the days of my appointed time will I
wait until my change come that thou that
thou shalt call and I will answer thee
that thou have a desire to the work of
thine hands. So what I'm showing here is
look when you're dead you're dead. The
dead in Christ will rise. But when does
that happen? At the last trumpet. When
is the last trumpet? After the plagues
are poured out. after the wrath is
passed and that's when the change comes
that Paul was talking about. We're
changed in the moment of the twinkling
of an eye at the last trumpet. So let's
compare.
Revelation 16:1 says, "And I heard a
great voice out of the temple saying to
the seven angels, go your way and pour
out the vials of the wrath of God." So
what is the wrath of God? When it says
that we will remain in our graves and we
won't be raptured until after your wrath
has passed, the wrath is the vials that
the seven angels are pouring out.
Because we're not going to be raptured
until that last trumpet after all the
plagues are poured upon the earth, then
we will be raptured to meet the Lord in
the air. And then the change is in 1
Corinthians 15:51-52
and it says, "Behold, I show you a
mystery. We shall not all sleep, but we
shall be changed. When does that happen?
In a moment, in the twinkle of the eye,
at the last trump. So, the Bible is so
perfectly clear
that when we die, we're dead. And that
the dead in Christ will rise first when
Christ comes again. But when does that
happen? It happens at the last trumpet.
Well, when is the last trumpet? Well,
Revelation describes seven trumpets. And
each trumpet is sounded when a plague is
poured upon the earth. when viles are
pou poured upon the earth and it says in
Job that we will be changed after God's
wrath is passed. The Bible is so clear
we need to study it line upon line
precept upon precept here a little there
a little by the mouth of two or three
witnesses. You can't take one verse that
says left behind and say look the Bible
says one will be left and the other be
taken. See preerttrip rapture proof case
closed. You cannot make doctrines out of
one verse taken out of context. For one,
read the whole verse. For another, read
the verses all around it. For another,
read the parallel scriptures. The Bible
is like a puzzle and it's got all the
answers, but you have to study it in in
a in a big picture. You can't look at
one puzzle piece and understand what the
whole puzzle is. The point of this
message is to prove to you that the
Bible says clearly that the second
coming is the is the rapture. that there
is no rapture beforehand. Why is it so
important to understand this? Because
churches are teaching millions of people
that look, we don't even have to worry
about understanding who the antichrist
is or what the mark of the beast is.
We're not even going to be here for
that. We're going to get out of here.
We're not even going to face
persecution. We're not going to see
tribulation. We are going to be saved.
And that is a lie from the pit of hell.
What's going to happen when the
Antichrist comes on the scene and the
mark of the beast is put into action and
people are still here and they're like,
"You know what? Everything I heard about
the Bible is a lie." The Bible isn't
true, but the Bible is true. The Bible's
a word of God and it has the truth. And
we must study it for ourselves. Study to
show thine own self approved. I hope
this message was edifying to you. I hope
it was eye opening. I hope it was clear.
Most of all, if it was, please give it a
thumbs up. It really helps this channel
to grow, helps this video to get out to
many others who might be deceived with
this last days deception. If you know
somebody that still believes in this
pre-tribulation doctrine, please share
this video with them. Show them the
scriptures to prove from the Bible alone
that Jesus is coming. He's coming soon,
but he's coming at the last trumpet
after the plagues. I love you. God
bless. I'll see you next time on Candid
Truth.